Televisa presents the importance of supporting the team.
Green medals to increase healing and white medals for HP.
There are tamps to emphasize allies and share experience.
The de goce is a great flavor to heal in the area,
ideal for pops who fight hand to hand.
You,
as a sapor,
must keep your distance to heal your team but not fall.
The pollen ball movement takes time to heal and pisses well.
Sporagodon is for stunear,
but it also takes a long time to activate.
Here the cat got in and almost stole targets.
The last one.
The baby is stun and healed in an area used over the largest number of allies.
No shit,
No.
Trapped.
Oh,
help,
help.
We bring great damage and resistance.
Although Rayquaza was about to leave,
we decided to press.
It was too much pressure and I fell.
Weakness.
Run him,
,
run him,
run him.
Without healing,
the team better fled.
Run him,
,
run him,
run him.
It was a great game and a good victory.
Such shelters are not found on a daily basis.